when someone turns on a video they are
very quickly trying to answer two
questions about you can I trust you can
I rely on you I really recommend a real
background research actually shows we do
not like fake backgrounds it's very
distracting if I was starting a brand
new YouTube channel today the first
thing I would do is keyword research a
lot of it deep dive on those keywords in
my videos often when I'm sharing
something that I think is really
important or I really want to emphasize
it I'll literally lean into the camera
like this is it welcome back to the
think media podcast today's episode is
psychological tricks to instantly boost
YouTube views and become more
charismatic on camera Our Guest expert
today is Vanessa van Edwards who's a
multi-time best-selling author a
renowned
researcher of professional communication
and Leadership she's on her way to
900,000 YouTube subscribers as well with
over 50 million video views so she's
very unique because she really helps
entrepreneurs business owners ERS
creators and communicators sharpen their
skills and ultimately achieve better
results with their content with their
communication and so this is going to be
a powerful Deep dive conversation
Vanessa welcome to the show thank you
for having me what a what a beautiful
way of introducing me I'm so happy to be
here so grateful for you I know we have
some mutual friends um I'm a big fan of
your books uh but I want to actually
just start off with some Rapidfire tips
what are some quick tips for making a
great impression on video
okay number one is the distance between
your nose and the camera so you should
measure the distance between your nose
and the camera and you should try to be
a foot and a half to three feet away
very specifically the reason for that is
because in human behavior research
researchers have found that there is
this called proxemics the study of space
there are four zones for people and the
public zone is the Zone that's farthest
away then we get to the social Zone this
is about 5 to seven feet away then we
get to the personal Zone this is where
we we have most of our onetoone
conversations where we feel comfortable
at in a coffee shop or talking to
someone in the break room or on a date
and the last zone is called the intimate
Zone that's about 18 Zer to 18 inches
away this is
preissing this is pre- Doctor exam pre-
dental exam the mistake that a lot of
people make on camera is they get too
close to their camera and it triggers
invasive cues we don't even realize it's
happening but if I were to give my
entire do my entire videos really close
to the camera it would immediately be
like whoa back up now there's a caveat
to this which is if you have a really
intimate Channel you want to be0 to 18
inches away so for me my My Demo is
brilliantly smart professionals so I
know that they don't want to get
intimate with me nor do I want to get
intimate with them right I'm married
right it's not a dating channel so I
send a Quee right from the first start
of zero to of 18 to 3 feet away if
you're doing a dating Channel if you are
doing makeup tutorials you might
consider hitting that 0 to8 inches an
example of this is um Limitless the
documentary on I think it's Netflix with
um uh Hemsworth have you seen that
documentary I've seen that documentary
very cool okay so they shot him zero to8
inches away if you look at him doing his
interviews it's so close to his face I
went ah human behavior Q they are
signaling you with the content we're
going to get personal we're g to get
deep Hemsworth is going to share so
think about space in terms of how you
want to be intimate with your audience
so powerful and you shared tip number
one just give us tip number two for
making a great impression on video hands
so hand gestures from a biological
perspective we love to see gestures and
what happens on video is we forget about
our G gestures we're thinking a lot
about our content our delivery our face
maybe our hair right what we forget
about is our gestures so research finds
that we put a lot of mental focus onto
gestures so for example right now I'm
speaking with my hands if I were to say
I have a really big idea but I were to
hold my fingers up really small your
brain is more likely to believe my
gesture over my over my my words if I
were to say today I want to talk to you
about five big ideas but hold up the
number three your brain is more likely
to believe my gesture and that is
because it's really that was so hard to
do by the way like just try right now
just say five but hold up three ready
five five five is horrible right does
your brain hurt yeah so the reason for
that is because our brain really likes
to be congruent with our gestures so the
when as viewers they know that highly
competent people know their content so
well they can speak to you on two tracks
they can speak to you with their words
but they can also speak to you with your
with their with their gestures or their
hands so a really good speaker
especially a captivating um video
creator they're saying hey everyone they
show their hand usually with some sort
of you know wave or greeting which I do
every time we see a palm we meet relax
and they're often demoing their concepts
with their words which increases
retention and also increases
memorability so people are more likely
to remember three points points hold up
three fing well you're already tapping
into this powerful idea of cues you're
the author of Q's Master The Secret
Language of charismatic communication
tell us what even is a q oh yes so a q
is a subtle but powerful social signal
now we are sending thousands of these
social signals every video they come in
four channels and we often don't realize
we have four ways to communicate our
cues the first one is the most obvious
our words our verbal communication and
that's not just how clear we are it's
also words we use to cue Behavior so we
are always on the lookout for Behavioral
cues second is our voice so how we say
our words our volume our Pace our
Cadence third is our body language or
non-verbal our facial gestures our hand
gestures our posture our movement in
space and the last one is is our
ornaments that's the colors we wear in
our YouTube videos what's behind us in
our YouTube videos any props we have The
Branding fonts colors we use and our
animations or our captions those are
four opportunities that you have to
influence how someone behaves or how
they feel connected to you and how did
cues come about uh what was the origin
story of you starting to observe these
things and collect these cues yes so I'm
a recovering awkward person my YouTube
channel is all about being awkward and
having to learn social skills from
scratch I'm not a natural extrovert I'm
not naturally good with people and so um
I did not understand cues I felt like I
had missed the memo on how you should
interact with people how to make
conversation um what to do with your
hands how to stand how to read faces and
so it actually started as a personal
project of mine where I wanted to
catalog literally create like a like a
dictionary or Encyclopedia of cues for
myself and as I was doing this spent
number of years doing this in the
beginning part of my career I realized
that a there were patterns B there was
research there was really interesting
research on these cues Universal cues
there are some cultural cues of course
but there's Universal ones and I created
these 96 cues in these four different
channels and I thought you know maybe I
should share some of these cues so I
started to share some on my YouTube
channel just like to test the waters
YouTube is amazing I I'm so grateful to
YouTube because it is the it was the
Tipping Point in my career like my
started on YouTube not my blog so
YouTube is so amazing because it allows
you to test content to see how it will
do so I just started slowly analyzing
cues on YouTube and I started YouTube in
2007 so I've been on YouTube for a long
time and I've been doing a video a week
since 2007 talk about a Content
treadmill that's it's a whole different
issue I started I did a video you know
analyzing the Rocks Alpha cues just for
fun just to like see what would happen
like breaking down how the rock is the
rock um I did one on Britney Spears
deception cues and obviously they did
very very well on YouTube and I went
okay there's something here and that's
when I pitched this was my second book
so I pitched that to my um publisher and
it turned out to be more successful than
I ever could have imagined so yeah what
are like two or three of the most
powerful cues that would make an
immediate impact on viewer retention on
YouTube and improving our content online
I'm going to give really small ones
because I think they're the that are
overlooked I like to think of qes like a
golf swing right like a golf swing you
can hit the ball but if you want to get
the ball to the right place there are
these micro adjustments in your stance
and your hands it's the same thing with
cues we know the obvious ones right like
make eye contact we know that QE right
smile if you feel happy we know that one
like those are cues those are great um
but I like the small ones that I think
differentiate a good Creator from a
great Creator so one of my favorites is
the lean so remember how I mentioned the
four zones of space so as I began to
study these cues I watched thousands of
hours of TED Talks my team and I
actually coded every single Ted Talk
that was posted from 2010 looking for
patterns I wanted to know what were the
differences between the most viewed TED
talks and the least view TED talks like
I you know if you watch Ted these are
all successful smart people why is it
that some videos get millions of views
and some get thousands of views so we
catalog these videos I thank my research
team thank you research team we
cataloged every single cue we could find
we clocked a number of smiling we looked
at stage presence we looked at gestures
one of the big things that we found was
that the really good speakers they use
space to their advantage and they would
use leans when they really wanted you to
pay attention so they were literally
crossing the space zone so in my videos
often when I'm sharing something that I
think is really important or I really
want to emphasize it I'll literally lean
into the camera like this is it and I
think it wakes people up like it
immediately medely makes people like oh
she's leaning in I better get it it's
very subtle it's a couple of inches in
fact one research study studied lean so
if you want to do a little experiment
with me so wherever you are right now
just lean forward three inches just give
it a
second they found that just doing that
activates a certain part of your
prefrontal cortex that is
pre-action so when I move in it actually
gives me energy so it imbus my words a
little bit more energy it makes me look
like I'm telling you something really
good but also sometimes listeners
viewers will lean in to the video like
literally they hear they see the lean
they lean themselves and that's makes
them more likely to like more likely to
subscribe they're literally pre-action
you're activating that prefrontal cortex
and I think and I've looked at my
analytics on this when I lean in a video
I get more engagement on the video I get
more replays on that section so those
are like the most replayed parts of my
videos and I get more engagement so I I
think that there's something to that so
elen is a small one but it's so powerful
wow so powerful and um we're going to be
covering all kinds of cool things your
YouTube tips from being consistent since
2007 YouTube business lessons that
you've learned as well as also generally
how to be more charismatic on video and
a lot of other topics we want to cover
but I think I want to make sure
listeners know that uh cues is an
essential book to pick up and so of
course that'll be in the the show notes
you can imagine how knowing all these
different cues and progressively
implementing them in your content could
really be helpful so definitely take
advantage of that uh resource um but
what have you learned you're a very
prolific content creator I was also
originally I think our mutual friend
Rory Vaden was talking about you I saw
your powerful presence as an author and
in a world of as you said kind of a
little bit of the corporate world you
know smart people speaking all this
different things but one of the rare
things I observed was you're on way to
900,000 subscribers and I think that
YouTube is one of the biggest missed
opportunities by a lot of women
entrepreneurs by a lot of entrepreneurs
in general um and sometimes they're more
active on other platforms you're like a
YouTube Legend you've been on the
platform since 2007 yeah um break down
some of the lessons that you've learned
after posting
570 videos to your channel oh wow yes so
many okay first first big lesson was I
went from casual to formal to somewhere
in between and I share that because I
think there's a Temptation for creators
to script or to overly practice or to
overly rehearse before a video and
there's a very fine line between
prepping for a video knowing your
content getting in getting out being
tight and being overly rehearsed or
overly formal so when I first started on
YouTube 2007 so just to paint the
landscape for anyone who has remembered
that time YouTube was like this new Wild
West no one knew what it was it was
pretty much just unboxing videos like
that that's really all it was very few
people were teaching on there and so in
the very beginning it was very informal
I was doing it like with a very casual
camera no lighting I did a couple out
like in a restaurant oh my gosh you know
very very casual then YouTube got real
serious people were like oh YouTube is a
thing and that's when there was a time
between 2009 to like 2014 or 15 where it
was like professional lighting makeup
amazing backgrounds amazing Studios and
so people were investing a ton in their
technology and that's when I got really
tight that's also when I got to film at
YouTube studios in LA and it got I my
videos started decline actually at that
point like I was getting a lot of views
at first and then I realized I was like
pumping out these videos on a beautiful
set 4K you know cameras and perfect
perfect teleprompter Scripts and I
started to lose engagement started to
lose views and I think what was
happening then is it felt robotic and so
I beg you do not use a
teleprompter please please do not use a
teleprompter I know it feels safe I know
it feels comfortable I know you want to
keep it tight and deliver the best
content you can but it kills Charisma
like it is almost impossible to read a
teleprompter script as a human it
doesn't matter how kis you are and so I
had to wean myself off
teleprompters because we were watching
my analytics and I was like like my they
don't do as well so now I'm back to no
teleprompter and I I don't have one in
my studio because it's too tempting when
it's on uh bullets and prep but I think
the big lesson I learned was like real
you have to act like you're hopping into
a conversation with a friend powerful
and break down your workflow today is it
do you come up with your content alone
are you thoughtful about this is what my
title is going to be I'm going to craft
that this is what the text and the
thumbnail is going to be what is your
current workflow as you're coming up
with video ideas okay so I for about 10
years I was a one-woman show edited all
my own videos and all my own Graphics
that was very very hard if you're if
you're a one man or one woman show I I
give you so much strength and credit and
like I'm sending you so much energy
because it is so hard and I I get it
I've been there you're doing a great job
like that's what I want to say if you're
if you're doing it on your own now I
have a team so that I'll break down my
workflow so I am very purposeful with
every aspect of my videos because we
make a little bit of money on ad Revenue
but actually we've turned off ads on a
lot of our videos because they sell so
many books and so many of my courses so
I'm I know exactly who I'm reaching so
my viewer on YouTube and this is both
based on analytics as well as just who
we know is watching are high achieving
professionals that want to level up
their skills and they're usually very
talented very smart but they need a
little help on the awkwardness
confidence side so I know who they are
um and typically the very first thing we
do is we start with keyword research so
I have a team member shout out to Rob
Rob does keyword research for me at the
beginning of every month where he is
sitting in ah refs that's the tool that
we use and he is looking for topics that
our people are searching so this is
everything from confidence at work to
introverts at work to talking to my boss
to dealing with difficult people at work
to ice breakers in meetings all those
topics he's looking for for
opportunities we specifically look for
medium volume but not a lot of
competition I don't even try on the big
traffic ones they're too hard and medium
volume is it that's like my people so um
like an example would be tips for
introverts at work right that that's a
really specific title so we take those
keywords um he does research in both
Google and YouTube and that is because
YouTube is a search engine you should
only think of it as a search engine um
and so uh we look and see what are the
keywords also what are the longtail
keywords this is kind of a little secret
hack which I think is really helped us
is because of AI our keyword um patterns
are changing from now from up until this
point people use short phrases they type
into YouTube or Google tips for
introverts introverts at work but what's
happening with AI is more and more
people are using an AI tool to search
the web and so they're going to type in
a much longer response so it might might
be tips for introverts working in an
open Office Space it might be tips for
introverts talking to their boss and
colleagues at work tips for introverts
making friends at work so now we're
taking all the longtail keywords and
those are my chapters so I have my main
video and then I have chapters broken in
there so I get all that keyword research
from my uh Team Member Rob and then I
start to bullet point also um I have a
team member a couple writers who help me
with research so looking in the academic
databases what research is there I've
noticed that differentiates my videos
from just random tips as if I can say
one research study from 2011 found that
84% of people are introverts at work
whatever it is um those are great for
social Clips because we make shorts out
of our long videos so and my team look
for research Clips on the topic then I
bullet point you know I begin to uh I
don't script but begin to write out kind
of the structure of the video uh then I
film I do not spend too much time
writing and practicing I try to do it a
little bit more C ual a little bit more
informal then it goes to my team member
Carolyn and she edits it for me edits
the video she also pulls out two or
three shorts from the video sometimes we
wait on shorts to see what are the most
replayed parts of the video and then we
only use those as shorts then she
creates thumbnails for us using canva we
also then do really heavy keyword
descriptions to make sure the
description is really uh keyword
friendly and then so it's a very it's a
very long answer I don't know if you
wanted this long an answer um then it
goes into then we have an article that
gets created so one of our writers uh
creates an article from my video but
makes it way longer my sweet spot for
videos at the moment and this changes
based on the year on YouTube uh is about
four to 14 minutes something in there
remember I'm not going for ad Revenue so
I am not doing it based on the ad
interstitials I'm doing it purely based
on content get in get out and most of my
professionals have a 10 to 20 minute
lunch that's what I'm going for or their
commute um so then they turn into an
article art are usually 5 to 10,000
words typically so they're they're
really Beast like they're long and then
we embed the video on the top of the
article and then I sent it out to my
newsletter we have about 500,000 people
on our newsletter which drives a lot of
of those early clicks that usually
happens in the first 24 hours then the
video often goes to all of our socials
and that is it that was such a tactical
answer a lot of value there and one of
the things that you were also mentioning
with which was a powerful YouTube secret
for social media across the board but
also YouTube videos was being warm in
your content can you break that down yes
so um remember how I talked about
scripting is the death of Charisma I
think that there's a couple ways you can
add warmth to your videos so one take a
step back is Princeton University found
that we are very quickly judging people
on two traits warmth and competence
those are the two most important traits
in all of our communication this is
especially important on video when
someone turns on a video they are very
quickly trying to answer two questions
about you can I trust you can I rely on
you so can I trust that you're who you
say you are can I rely on you to give me
good information that's what they're
trying to answer within the first couple
seconds of your video right that's what
they're trying to answer I think that a
lot of creators go for competence I
certainly did right like in those formal
years I was like hit them with the
science right like tip tip tip and my
videos were very robotic if you look at
videos from that time period you can see
on my YouTube channel where I'm like 77%
of leaders need to be more confident
with their voice here are the five ways
that you can like it was extremely
helpful but not relatable at all I was
missing warmth so how does warmth look
on video so there there are specific
cues for warmth um one is movement and
expressive it's
expressiveness so when someone is being
all about the comp
they're delivering like this they're
delivering with their voice they
delivering with their gestures there's
very little facial movement there's very
little movement in their in their in
their frame most of my thumbnails show
some kind of movement like typically
that's where I add warmth so it's me
waving it's me leaning in it's me making
a silly face and my videos are very
competent so it's not like I'm doing
something silly but movement is a way of
showing warmth in video it shows that
you're not being too scripted you're not
being too formal so movement facial
expressiveness
um especially in your first 10 seconds
so like for example um I was just doing
this yesterday when I was filming I was
teaching on uh how to introduce yourself
so we have a video coming up a key word
that we identified is how to introduce
yourself where people are nervous
introducing themselves they think it's
boring they don't know how to do it in
an interesting way so the video is how
to introduce yourself the first intro I
recorded was like this ever struggle
with how to introduce yourself I'm going
to give you five quick ways and a
formula for how you can introduce
yourself to anyone it looked so boring
when I watched it back I was like oh my
God like the the verbal was good but I
did not have enough expressiveness so
instead I recorded it something like
this where I added in the actual
awkwardness I feel in that situation so
it would be like have you ever had that
really awkward situation where you have
to introduce yourself but you don't know
how that facial expressiveness is
literally the feeling that I feel when I
have to introduce myself and it
immediately added warm to the video so
it's not just smiling it's any kind of
facial expressiveness what a power tip
adding warmth in your content and what
an Insight from the science revealing
that trust and competency and if we can
think about weaving that into our
content we could get a lot better
results and impact more people and we
also discussed before we got started
today about some of the lessons you've
learned kind of from the business side
of YouTube and man it's wild it's funny
the same year I started was 2007 as well
cool and so 16 years ago um fast forward
to today Goldman Sachs research said
that the crater economy is going to be a
half a trillion dollar industry um over
the next five years it's going to double
and who would have thought that this is
now the fastest growing small business
type is what signal fire and Yahoo
finance was talking about this whole
Creator economy which is sometimes hard
to Define because you've got maybe
personal brands or Educators or speakers
that have books and other things but
then it's also the primary business
whether it's fan funding or ad revenue
and such a Divergent group that has
discovered the power of the Creator
economy what have you learned in the
business side of YouTube well first of
all can I just point out what you did
excellently Sean you're very charismatic
but I just want to point out for for
people watching so if you are primarily
warm so I just gave an example of being
very competent you might be the other
way where like you're doing very casual
videos you're very warm so you also need
to add competence competence comes stats
facts and credibility markers so Sean
just did it so Sean's been very warm
this whole interview because he's trying
to make me feel comfortable but he just
added a fact to a question which is
immediately adding a balance of
competence and warmth so if you are a
highly warm Creator the more you can uh
add credible sources you know the Wall
Street Journal just quoted or 77% of BL
right like that immediately adds
competence so excellent job sir
excellent job sir so um I was so excited
by that that I forgot the question but I
believe your question was about business
YouTube business okay what have you
learned okay um so I mentioned the
keyword research which I think is big I
also think I'm sure you talk about this
a lot already on your podcast so I won't
go into it if you talk about a lot but
Hub hero and help content do you talk
about that a lot we've never broke that
down here break it down okay so um I
actually got this from YouTube so we
have a YouTube rep um which is so
amazingly helpful um I thank you YouTu
for for offering guidance and they
explained to me that there are three
buckets of content this was a helpful
way to break it down hero Hub and help
so your Hub content is the videos that
you want every one of your subscribers
to watch they are foundational they are
about you and your brand or their
foundational Concepts that you believe
in the world your big idea so for me
this would be um my confidence video my
communication videos and my body
language videos those for me are Hub
content I want every one of my
subscribers to watch them first those
are going to Anchor your channel they
might even be the featured video on your
channel they also might be your first
playlist and the First videos in your
playlists um and you want to drive
people to those first and when you think
about those those are the big keywords
typically um if you're a new Creator I
like to think of 10 10 and 10 10 Hub 10
hero 10 help so you should have at least
10 hub videos the next one is help these
are videos that they're not foundational
but are great skills that are going to
help your viewer so for me how to
introduce yourself that's a help video
that's not foundational right like not
every person's going to have that but
it's a great little social skill that
someone might want or like one I just
did was how to be funny which is like
I'm not funny naturally um but I in my
work I have to learn how to be a little
funny I do believe that laughter is the
lubrication of learning love the
literation all my literation pans so I
have to be a little funny in my videos
and I've had to learn it so that's a
specific help full skill that most of my
subscribers will find helpful those are
also your big keyword terms that is like
how to or if you're not a how-to person
it would be um an entertaining video
that your viewer would find fun and
interesting but isn't foundational to
you the last one is hero content hero
content is content that no one's going
to search for there are no keywords for
it it
isn't essential for your brand but it's
super BuzzFeed
super clickable um super just captures
someone interest so for example if you
were a a homemaker like I follow a lot
of moms I'm a mom of two so I love
watching Moms on YouTube because I don't
do any parenting content so a lot of the
moms they'll have uh their Hub content
would be um how to set up your home or
um under $100 meal prepping for four
children right like that that would be
Hub content their Hub content would be
um my favorite keep your freezer clean
clean hacks not essential but helpful
their hero content would be meal prep my
10 minute dinner ideas no one is GNA
search meal prep 10minute dinner ideas
but if I love an influencer I am gonna
watch her 10-minute meal prop ideas does
that make sense like those kind of
buckets so you want to think about your
content in those ways as opposed to
trying to do everything with one video
if you try to do it all with one video
it just it it's not going to hit anyone
hey in just a second we're going to get
back into the episode but if you haven't
heard for a limited time you can get
OnDemand access to my YouTube strategy
class entirely for free at think
masterclass.com on the class you're
going to learn the one strategy that we
use at think media that is currently
generating over 300,000 views every
single day if you are new to YouTube
this is going to help you start right
and avoid mistakes and if you're already
a pro this is going to help you multiply
your growth and the cool thing is the
class is 100% free and you can watch it
instantly on demand all you got to do is
go to think masterclass.com or just
click the link in the show notes to get
instant access all right let's jump back
into the episode absolutely brilliant um
a few more questions in a rapid fire
question that different than I'm I'm so
long-winded there's I can't do any rapid
fire so as long as I'm usually Landing
the plane taxing the runway and uh so
you could take as long as you want to
answer but this was just kind of in the
middle of our content creation and being
powerful communicators uh one of the
questions I wanted to ask you was what
tips do you have for looking great on
Zoom meetings and so even if someone's
not a content creator yet and I think
about even the think media team we try
we're all remote there's almost 30 of us
with contractors now and our team is
growing and we are trying to build
culture for a remote workplace and so
that can be hard to do we're trying to
say hey have your camera on and so what
are some tips maybe for looking great on
Zoom meetings connecting on Zoom
meetings and for leaders trying to lead
remote teams yes so that's most of my
folks so um how to look good on camera
how to lead with influence on video Is
My Jam so and these go for creators or
Zoom meetings or video presentations
first is the first 10 words you say what
are those first 10 words making them
purposeful and second is how you say
those first 10 words so let's start with
the how the biggest mistake that people
make on video is they start when they're
most anxious so when we're nervous we're
waiting for our Zoom to pop up or
waiting for our camera to be on we
taking a deep breath like this and we
say hi hey
everyone at the very top of our breath
it's when we're most nervous so when we
analyze all these video calls we notice
that people give away their vocal
confidence in the first 10 seconds
typically it's because they start really
high in their vocal C they start really
high in their vocal range this is for
both men men and women so right now I'm
working very hard to use the lowest end
of my natural range I'm going to tighten
my vocal cord so you can hear what it
sounds like when I'm anxious or a little
bit nervous I tend to go higher into my
range I also get a little bit of vocal
fry so when I'm anxious or nervous I
tend to sound like this now imagine if I
were to give an entire presentation in
this tone of voice it would drive you
crazy and that is because we hear the
anxiety and we're like no so what
happens is we're most nervous the very
beginning of our call and so we start up
so what I want you to make sure of is
you do not hold your breath on your
first few words right so instead of
hello good to see everyone I want you to
make sure you're speaking on the out
breath so hey good to see everyone those
are two totally different vocal
Impressions and the first 10 seconds of
a video you're going to lose someone
you're gonna get someone that's high
warmth and high competence so speak on
the out breath do not hold your breath
second do not ask your name it's such a
silly one but research shows I can even
you can talk to you about the doctor
study if you want but research shows
that when we ask a statement it triggers
someone to go from listening to
scrutinizing so if I were to say hey my
name is Vanessa I am a YouTuber and I
write books you immediately think of me
as less competent and that's because I'm
asking things that should be said so I
want you to go back and listen to a
couple Zoom meetings or listen to a
couple of your recent videos and
identify every single time you ask a
statement that's going up at the end of
your sentence every time you do that
you're giving away a little bit of your
bical power you're giving away a little
bit of your bial confidence so I want
you to state your name and not rush
through it so that happens a lot on
videos I am guilty of this I'm working
on the rushing through I have a long
name Vanessa van Edwards and I used to
be like
V because it made me nervous to say it
so slow down your name state your name
don't ask it so that's the how um there
are about 15 different vocal cues that
you want to think about if you're doing
a lot of video but those are the two
most important ones the second thing is
the kinds of words you use most people
throw away the first 10 words they say
especially in a zoom call typically the
first 10 word someone says is I can't
see I help can you can you see me can
you hear me high up all question
flection throwing away the words so Sean
we first hopped on I made sure I said
hello I was going to see you and then I
asked if you like my microphone right
and then I was like do like the way it
sounds so your first 10 words should be
very purposeful they should be something
warm and competent hey I'm so honored to
be here I can't wait to meet everyone on
this meeting right like even as simple
as that it makes you sound positive it
sets up the meeting for Success it is so
critical that we don't also accidentally
start negative oh this weather man sorry
I'm late that traffic um hold on hold on
let me just get my coffee uh we're gonna
wait for everyone to log on when we
check our email no no more no more
purposeful Impressions only please man
these are such powerful nuances because
there's challenges that we have with
being in remote teams and building
culture has its own challenges and so
you're trying to do a lot in terms of
tone energy emotion and so these are
some very practical te uh things before
we move on what about looking great on
video and for anybody you coach or
encourage do you encourage people to
invest in decent equipment or decent
microphone or even if they just have
their MacBook and a webcam and airpods
any tips for showing up great on video
yes so um I really recommend a real
background research actually shows we do
not like fake backgrounds it's very
distracting to the eye we also see it as
a little bit inauthentic our brain
cannot help but wonder what's back there
and also you cannot control when you
raise your hand up and your hands
disappear it is so distracting for the
brain so please I would even more than
lighting I would rather you get a real
background like that's a real background
behind me right so please real
background I would rather have a plain
real wall like literally a plain wall
then a fake background I would even if I
had to choose pick a somewhat dirty
living room over a virtual one and
that's saying a lot now hopefully you
don't have a dirty living room but real
so real background um that really helps
you look better seriously um second is I
think investing in gear is okay but one
is I would make sure that it's your
fronting so you're angling your body
towards the camera too often I see
people wear their cameras off to their
side and they're typing like this that's
actually a disrespectful non-verbal cue
when you're angled away so make sure
that wherever your camera is it's in
line with your toes right so it's in
line with your toes um please do away
with swivel chairs unless you can help
but not swivel in them so I'm saying
standing right now because I'm a naughty
swiveler um when I'm on video so I do
not let myself sit down when I'm on
video um so if you can stand that
definitely helps you deliver better it
helps you look better um swivel chairs
are
distracting and oh yes eyeline so um
there's a lot of research now that's
looking at where our angle is so if you
look up at someone typically it's um you
do see that person as more confident
because they look taller and bigger but
actually if you want to have an equal
relationship with someone I highly
recommend having your camera at eye
level so my camera is exactly at eye
level like to the to the inch so if you
can get at eye level try not to go down
or up so it doesn't have to be expensive
gear it's actually all about the
positioning these tips are gold because
there are some small tweaks that we can
make to our current setups to connect
better and man as professionals maybe
we're in a selling situation we're in a
coaching situation we're in a Content
creation situation even camera placement
could power up our next video or have us
make an better impression in our
workplace virtually I really am curious
though you you've coined the Caris the
Charisma formula that has cues from D
Vinci's Last Supper and highlights the
non-verbal cues of some powerful figures
what is the Charisma formula yeah so the
Charisma formula is warmth cues plus
competence cues so there are 96 qes and
I break them down into warm compet
charismatic there are a few cues that
are so good they hit the balance and
then danger zone and danger zone cues
are like don't do these they're Negative
they show guilt or deception and you
don't want to do them um so that what's
interesting is I think these cues are
everywhere and I think they often
explain why things go viral what's the
original viral image the last supper
right it's like one of the most known
images in the world and I think it's
because it holds some really intrinsic
Universal cues there are cultural cues
but there's some Universal cues so for
example um I I spent a lot of time
looking at this image and breaking down
all the cues that are in it the very
simplest is that if you measure the
amount of space each person in that
picture takes up Christ takes up the
most amount of space and we recognize
this as a universal gesture of Pride so
research from un University of British
Columbia found that across cultures and
genders and races when we feel pride and
we feel confidence we take up space
usually have space between our torso and
our arms so a thing to think about for
YouTube is um you know Amy Cuddy back in
the day did a TED Talk where she talked
about power posing I like power posing
but like I'm not going to power pose in
my videos I'm I'm not gonna be like I'm
here everyone right I'm not gonna stand
with my arms wide but what's more
important is actually the distance
between our torso and our arms so the
way that I have my setup is that I
almost always have space between my
torso and my arms and I also have
maximized the distance between my
earlobes and my my shoulder so we're
taking up as much space as possible so
in the Last Supper Christ is not only
taking up the most amount of space but
he has his arms planted wi he has space
between his shoulders and his torsone he
has space between his ear loves and his
shoulder that's how you should sit on
Zoom honestly if you're on Zoom or
you're a Creator just like Channel
Christ in the Last Supper be like what
was Christ doing then that's what I
should do he also is showing a a head
tilt so a head tilt is a universal
warmth cue and that is because we're
trying to hear someone better we go
what' you say and we tilt our head to
expose our ear and so while he's the
most powerful posture wise he is also
showing warmth and that is the sweet
spot for leadership we like people who
show a balance of warmth cues and
competence cues deep insights you know
one of the most important aspects of
content creation is the visuals and of
course there's the colors of thumbnails
people actually get really geeky in the
science of thumbnails color choice um
and then there's even what we could wear
on our videos how we edit our videos
what are some tips for the psychology of
color imagery and profile picture
pictures and this could extend to our
marketing materials our branding and how
this comes into play when it comes to
cues so first is I think I am terrible
at imagery on YouTube so this is the
first thing is do not look at my videos
for any imagery cues I am terrible with
it that is because for many years I was
doing my own visual 's and I am a
teacher I am not a designer so do not
look at my channel for any of those tips
however what we did break down for Q's
is the color cues as well as ornament
cues so the way that you want to think
about ornament cues that last category
of cues is associations neural
associations so when someone sees a
political flag on a lapel right if I
were on this video and I was wearing an
American flag of my lapel you would
immediately think of politics right like
even if I didn't talk about politics
some how you'd be thinking that I was
political possibly even right leaning
possibly right so what you want to think
of is what are the ornaments saying so
for example in the background of Sean's
video we have tools like a hammer right
which immediately triggers me to think
practical actionable like getting into
it I also see his award which is a
credibility marker which means wow like
he's someone I want to learn from he's a
someone I want to Aspire to be he's
really successful on YouTube he also has
a couple of plants which shows a little
bit of warmth right so all of those cues
are subconsciously associate having
neural associations for me so when I
picked my background because we could
have done a a a back like a back screen
like a backdrop that they call them
behind me I was like no I want it to be
um super clean Super crisp and I want to
show real trees that's all I want real
trees and so that's something that I
like you to focus on my content you have
something kind of relaxing behind you
that's how I picked this I also for many
years taught in a studio with my
favorite chemicals behind me oxytocin
serotonin and dopamine and that's
because I use them as teaching AIDS so
not only were I would I know they were
creating neural associations to science
and my brand is called science people my
YouTube channel is called science people
so I was trying to double up on those
neural associations to my channel and my
branding but also it was great because
I'd be like oxytocin dopamine serotonin
and it was like a timesaver for me and
my Editor to not have to add those
images so I would say whatever you're
creating it just has to have the right
purposeful neural associations there are
no bad there's no bad color to wear on
YouTube there's no bad color to put in
your thumbnails it's all about what
associations they're bringing up for
your viewers so very interesting now you
also did an experiment on Shark Tank and
what was a surprising finding that you
got from Shark Tank in relationship to
Q's so um I love Shark Tank and again I
was always kind of curious if there were
patterns if you could more so could you
predict a winning pitch by just watching
the first few minutes like if you were
just to watch the it's all cut right
it's usually an hour and a half pitch
it's synthesiz into seven or eight
minutes but could you predict just
watching the first minute who was going
to win or who was going to lose and
there was some really clear variables or
clear um patterns that we saw with the
most likely to win pitches they weren't
in every winning pitch but they tended
to be winning pitches so the first one
was typically some kind of non-verbal
greeting so typically the most
successful pitchers literally physically
greeted the Sharks they'd be like hey or
uh good morning like they would do some
sort of open Palm gesture to the Sharks
listening I think that was a a warmth
cue but B these sharks are hearing you
know dozens of pitches in a day I think
when they felt acknowledged even
subconsciously they were like ah
friendly like I can trust this person so
some sort of non-verbal greeting I do
this from stage do this on video I think
it's really important um the second
thing that we thought was thought was
really surprising is um interactivity of
the pitch helps predict a winning pitch
so having them touch a product smell a
product taste a product play a game and
you'll notice earlier I had us all play
a game where I had us lean in that is
interaction right that is something
that's going to switch someone from just
listening to actually interacting with
the person and so I've taken that in
almost all of my videos I try at least
if it's longer than five minutes to do
some kind of interactivity if I can
that's amazing some of my favorite talks
um they get the audience involved do
this with your hands do this with your
neighbor stand on your feet and those
become very memorable so those are some
fascinating insights my my talks always
you know we're not talking about stage
presence but um my talks that is the
critical thing is I want people to be
literally I'm changing modes every 30
seconds on stage so you don't have time
to check your email you're you're you're
with me in every mode switch from stage
I want to ask you a question about a
phenomenon on in our Modern Age and that
is celebrity apology
videos there is a major almost now meme
culture around YouTuber apology videos
people react to them people um put them
together with all kinds of different
meme formats across the internet they
spread onto different channels like
YouTubers who have done something or
said something bad yeah and and and it
typically it's probably something bad
but you know how prevalent cancel
culture could be but here's some
examples okay so Colleen Ballinger AKA
Miranda Sings did a UK she actually did
a song with a ukulele her fans accused
her of grooming them uh as teens some of
them and from uh difference she was
accused from performing um Beyonce song
black-faced again these are just
allegations and a lot of people dig up
old Social Media stuff take it out of
context but maybe you've heard the story
of now Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunes is
apology video um they recently were um
supporting uh Danny Masterson they wrote
a letter to the judge but then they
wrote they they made an apology video it
seems to be that each of these
individuals apology video almost has
like no uh chance of of being helpful it
usually backfires and one of the most
recent stories is uh Drew Barrymore
started to uh decided to restart her
talk show despite the Hollywood writer
strike and so this was um announced on
September 10 that she was her show was
coming back um and then the writer
strike started to you know critique that
she made an apology video it did not go
over well in most cases these videos
eventually get deleted but the internet
is undefeated you can never actually
delete them and so I'm curious I mean
you've done some research on lie
detection and I'm curious how you know
what you learned there but maybe in
light of this this idea of seeing people
are they authentic um is this just
cancel culture is there maybe something
we could learn from this phenomenon of
apology videos typically not going over
well or maybe the way they're done and
some people even break them down play
byplay natural organic setting don't you
know makeup not done uh kind of look
like you did it off the cuff uh sort of
you know some people would say
manufacture tears and of course I know
the internet could be very critical and
our show comes from a place of empathy
for all involved and wanting to give
people the benefit of the doubt but I
think especially with a communication
expert like yourself I'm curious about
your thoughts on
authenticity lie detection and all of
the above yes so I think that there's a
really important takeaway from these
videos all failing which is they're all
all rehearsed right you would never even
if you're off the cuff you would never
not rehearse a a little bit before a
major apology video and I remember how
we talked about the very beginning that
was the death almost of my channel was
rehearsing too much being overly formal
it really kills your authenticity it
really kills your charisma and so my
hypothesis is that you've done something
horrible or something that you've you
know misconstrued or shared
misinformation or whatever and now you
have to do an apology video that could
be coming from a lawyer that could be
demanded from your fans even if you
think you have to do it you're not going
to do it without rehearsing a little bit
right so you're going to spend some time
in the mirror or with a partner or with
your lawyer you know practicing through
that went maybe you even do a couple of
takes you know five or six different
videos and you take the final one people
pick up on that lack of authenticity I
want say lack of authenticity because
they could be genuinely apologizing they
could genuinely feel bad but we sense
out too formal something feels rehearsed
something feels practiced so even the
most authentic apology someone who's
truly sorry if they've rehearsed it five
six seven times we instinctively pick up
on those cues is very very hard to add
Charisma authenticity when you were over
rehears or overly formal which is I'm
that's why I'm so glad you're bringing
it up is that is the number one killer
of Charisma on YouTube for creators wow
and then did you already touch on your
research with lie detection and how that
could come into play here so of course
someone could be lying and uh Li
detection is interesting because when
you look at the science the hardest the
biggest challenge we have with light
detection research is
the difference between guilt right guilt
is from Liars the Liars feel guilty and
a true negative emotion right so it's
very very hard to distinguish the two so
if someone's a liar and they feel guilty
about their lie guilt can leak out in
different kinds of cues then anger or
sadness or fear right someone who's
honest and accused of being a liar can
show anger and honesty and fear anger
and um disgust and fear and so the
biggest challeng that we have is
differentiating the two in an apology
video it would be almost impossible to
differentiate the both because if
someone's been accus of something and
they're lying about it they're going to
show guilt and probably anger and if
they're not if they're telling the truth
they really are sorry they're probably
going to feel sadness and remorse and so
it's very very hard to untangle those
cues that's why there isn't one
Pinocchio's nose right there isn't we
just know oh yep that person was lying
and so in our research we're trying to
untangle
those two things and it's very hard it's
also really hard with a sociopath or a
narcissist sociopaths and narcissist
sometimes don't feel guilt so they will
lie and have no negative emotions at all
so it's a very very complex science I'm
I love doing research on it because I
find it really fascinating and there are
patterns you know um I talk about how to
spot a bad guy or how to spot a bad girl
in my book of what are the cues that are
often deceit or at least red flags where
you see them and you're like huh what
was that wait what um because there are
a couple cues that I think um
statistically speaking show they can
most often be deceit I'm careful not to
say always because there is no
Pinocchio's nose such good insights um I
want to land the plane um do you have
four minutes yeah um with our final
segment after we also remind listeners
where they can connect with you I really
want to uh encourage listeners to check
out your book Q's that'll be linked up
in the show notes and your first book
Captivate both bestsellers um both
incredible uh resources that have direct
relevance for helping us be better as
content creators which is our goal here
on the think media podcast but also um
you've got so many cool things happening
where else can people find you and
connect with you sure so um our big
course people school is our Flagship
video course so I put out a ton of free
content on YouTube but if you want to be
more systematic about your cues and
about your warmth and competence that's
an a Very Advanced course it's kind of
like a college level people skills
course and so uh we are constantly
launching launching courses of that and
I even have a bonus specifically for
creators in that class because we have a
lot of creators who join so that's at my
website science of people.com amazing
and we'll link everything up in the show
notes okay Vanessa as we land the plane
this segment is called repeat after me
and so I will say the statement and then
you just repeat it and then finish that
statement okay um as a coach um to
content creators what is the biggest
mistake new content creators make I
think the biggest mistake that new
content creators make is ignoring
playlists because um the YouTube
algorithm the way that people discover
most of my content is related videos and
the way that we were able to get into a
lot of related videos was creating
playlists with other people's content
most people create playlists of just
their own content I think that is a huge
mistake unless you're you're a giant
author or other influencer um the best
thing you can do is think what video
would be the perfect video for someone
to watch before mine it might be
competitive it might be complimentary
but for every two videos you add to your
own playlist you should be adding a pre
video to the playlist of what you think
would be a great pre-roll because that
way you're teaching YouTube when people
watch this Ted talk or this video on
recipes mine should come next and that's
how you should align your playlist if I
was starting a brand new YouTube channel
today the first thing I would do is if I
today the first thing I would do is
keyword research keyword research a lot
of it a lot of it deep dive on those
keywords the most important mindset you
need as a content creator is the most
important mindset for a content creator
is feeling like your audience is your
friend I think when you talk at people
they don't like to be spoken at
especially when they're watching
watching you in their bed or in their
bathroom and so I think the more like
you can talk to someone like they're
having a conversation with you like I
literally think that everyone watching
my channel is a fellow recovering
awkward person and just wants like a
little bit of help um that mindset helps
me I think connect with people and also
um stay relevant if you are feeling
afraid to post your first video I
encourage you to if you're afraid to
post your YouTube video I encourage you
to always remember you could unlist it
right like my first 100 videos are now
unlisted uhuh and there's a reason for
that because they don't not my proudest
moments anymore and so it's so you could
always put it up for a week and see what
happens right you could always unlist it
and try something else later and final
question back when I was starting my
business I wish I knew the power of back
when I was starting my business I wish I
knew the power of leveraging other
platforms so the way that I built my
business other than YouTube was I went
to other platforms where they were
playing video so I was one of the first
instructors on udemy I was one of the
early maybe mid middle instructors but
um at the height of creative live that's
two platforms people were watching video
those were already my people if you're
in udemy or in Creative live you already
earn your self-help you already like
watching video I didn't want to go after
people who only listen to podcasts right
because I have video content I don't
even have a podcast so going to other
platforms you to me creative live
skillshare all of those LinkedIn
learning I hit those as hard as I could
I pitched my heart out for them and I
had to beg beg for them I had to really
really push to try to get on those
platforms because it was directly
reaching people who like video as a
medium so try to find other video
platforms they're different all the time
right creative live is much smaller now
UD me is much smaller now so what are
the current video platforms I have plays
in these as well right now big media
podcast the legendary Vanessa van
Edwards thank you so much what a
tactical and practical episode with so
much value of course check out the show
notes and we cannot wait to connect with
you in a future episode